yes okay so uh
a professor Jim Dowling he's an
associate professor at the kth Roger
Institute of Technology yes yeah so
please uh join me in our welcome to
Professor darling
thanks okay
right that was a challenge I learned a
bit I have a European computer in case
you guess it doesn't work in America
that's uh and yesterday actually I
couldn't get into my hotel because I had
to enter in a code and sent me an SMS
and a text message sorry an American
speaking text message not an SMS and it
said it doesn't you they can't receive
it because you've got a European phone
so it's been a good week so far
um okay so I'm gonna do uh so I I do
lecture and I also have a free course
called serverless ml that I ran last
Autumn or last fall and this is based
around that course but this course is
also given a kth
um over the winter and I changed the the
technologies that I used in that course
and the original one I used at this
feature store hopsworks but we also used
GitHub actions GitHub pages to build
serverless machine learning systems and
then we moved on to using modal and
hugging face in the in the fall or in
the the winter but I'm gonna I'm gonna
go through what we're doing what we're
trying to do here is build a production
machine Learning System in only python
end-to-end we'll try and do it in 90
minutes
we've already done this I've mentioned
the course if you're curious it's
available there we have a Discord which
we started about six weeks ago we've got
about a thousand people on it already
which is pretty uh good and if you want
to join along and I recommend you to
join along what you'll need to do is
register an account here at
apps.hobstructs.ai
and you also can optionally you don't
have to but it's it's good if you want
to follow on completely create an
account on modal.ai
and then you'll need to have a user
interface and the fact streamlits
probably be better than hooking face
hooking face is fine too but there's
some issues with ports I've discovered
in Hogan face I'll get to later
now the slides are available up there as
well so if you want to take a photo of
them you can jump ahead if you think I'm
going too slow
and what a service machine Learning
System is going to be is going to be
layers right it's going to have state
and in machine learning the state that
we have are the features that's the
input to the model the data so the
labels also can't as input to your
models when you're training we don't
have labels when we're predicting in
inference and then the models themselves
the models themselves are State and
we're going to use hopsworks for the
state
we're going to look at modal for the
compute
and we're going to look at a user
interface with either streamlit I'm
going to show stream at first and
hooking face as well now
um
what we get out of this is a system that
runs now all of these different Services
have very generous free tiers so I wrote
in the in the abstract it's a free
serviceml system there's tons of I think
there's 40 or 50 systems I know of right
now running on this stack out there
on payroll welcome okay we'll skip that
I know what's going on there
okay
now actually what I'm going to do I'm
going to show you before we start let's
show you what we're going to build
so it's an air quality prediction system
and I actually ran this as the standard
project for students who couldn't come
up with their own projects at kth in the
winter and there are tons of really good
ones one in particular in Poland was
really nice
but one of my guys just put this
together quickly it's basically you can
pick some locations so we have a bunch
here in Seattle and I need to run start
this running don't I okay now maybe it
looks like it's running okay and you can
see that we're collecting data
from Seattle about air quality
and in case you don't know this the
internet is full of free sources of data
so one of them is that a lot of people
are buying sensors with air quality and
they're putting them connecting to the
internet and you can get those
measurements via apis so what this
service does basically is you can pick
some places I'll pick a few here I've
forgotten to pick some
I'm sorry this is a this is not my
computer in case you're curious uh so
let's pick South Park because every oh
say this is me not being able to use a
Mac properly
um okay
you would think of this okay so let's
try that one there didn't like that so
I'm gonna have to I'm sorry this is
literally clicking on a mouse on the Mac
is what's getting me here okay so uh
let's go up did that one seem to work
let's delete it because I'm not sure if
it did
okay Bellevue I like that one
um let's put some more Tacoma we're over
in
uh I guess you you probably know these
places better than I do but anyway in
any case we picked some paces and we're
going to look at the air quality
prediction for the next week and you can
basically pick a bunch of them so we
Bellevue in here and you compare it to
Seattle you can see how your place is
compared to your neighbors so this is
running free on streamlit cloud it's
using uh the state that's in in
hopsworks and then once a uh once a day
we have a feature pipeline running on a
model which is collecting all the data
that came down all this is running for
free so I know hopefully you can see
that there but basically we've got this
red line is today so we've got the
hindsight predictions and then we've got
the predictions for the next week and it
looks pretty good for air quality
um you know maybe you want to do hay
fever that would be even better I think
what I say in the course is that there
are so many of these potential I call
them prediction services that you could
build it's mind-numbing and when I
discovered the other day was a
prediction of the NBA games at the end
NBA playoffs are ongoing there I thought
it was pretty cool and prediction of
football scores Bitcoin prices there's
tons of them
okay
so
the reason I'm telling you about this is
because actually I think the data
scientists as we know it today is a
little bit endangered species it's not
enough to train models anymore so if you
work at a large organization and we as a
company deal with very large
organizations they've all hired data
science teams they've put them in a room
and said go off and train some models
and there's often walls between the
teams you have like the data analytics
team they give it data dump to the data
scientists the data scientists trainer
model they give the model and hand it
over the world to some Ops people like
an ml engineer they're supposed to
deploy your model but they still need to
connect it back to the data to get
pre-computed features you basically you
end up with in Conway's law you
basically end up with this type of model
so Conway's law basically says that the
systems that you develop will be based
around the organizational structures
that you have so in this case it's
incredibly difficult to put models in
production but what it also implies is
that as a data scientist you're only
training models here you're not doing
anything else you're like my job's
training models that's it
um
the problem with doing it in this model
is that you're only working on static
data you're only working on a dump of
data and you're able to do one-off
prediction on that dump of data it's low
business value
because if you train a model
that's making predictions on new data
that comes in all the time and we saw
that with our air quality example
there's new data coming in every day
every day we get new weather predictions
every day we get new observations of the
air quality in these locations
now we can make predictions for the next
seven days I don't need to do anything
the system runs by itself so to do that
I need at least batch data in that
example I'm using batch data once a day
I have a batch feature pipeline which
pulls down the historical observations
of air quality and it also pulls down
and scrapes the weather predictions for
the next seven days and it writes it to
our feature store so this is pretty good
if you want to get to the to the top of
the business value chain this is Tick
Tock and you're doing real-time data so
as you swipe and Tick Tock the events of
your swipe and as you spend time viewing
a video that information gets sent to
eventually ultimate Kafka broker then
you'll have a technology called Flink
that processes it and within a second or
two that event is available in a feature
store for the model to use that to make
a prediction about what to recommend
next and that's why Tick Tock is
effectively uh you know crack digital
crack for kids because it's learning in
real time about what your preferences
are the last three three movies you've
watched how much time you spent on them
that information is available as
features when you make a prediction
about what to show next
these uh I call them prediction Services
because we're no longer just training a
model
um Charles runs this uh really
interesting course on on full stack deep
learning at Berkeley and he basically
said there in 2017 you needed to build
Michelangelo at Uber to do this this was
like an incredible thing and now you can
build these as just a part of the
student project so the students who did
these projects did it in two weeks here
we can see user interface for one of the
one of the groups there were two in each
group and they basically can show you
the predictions of air quality in Poland
so I never got around to doing this for
Seattle but it would be nice to redo
this for Seattle then you can check your
neighbors to see you know do you have
better air quality than your neighbors
this week
but there's a ton of these projects if
you're following the slides you can
click on the link there's about 25 of
them from from the class that I gave at
kth but there's tons of them out on
GitHub if you Google around for them
now
um the reason why students are able to
build these systems in two weeks is
because they're building a machine
Learning System but we're decomposing it
into smaller parts so what we're not
doing is saying here's go build a
machine learning pipeline now you have a
system
there is no one machine learning
pipeline there's no monolithic machine
learning pipeline that is your system
right you're a a machine learning system
that we see in production always always
consists of three parts so the ml
pipelines are in fact a feature
engineering step you take raw data and
you produce features
you have features and labels you get
models model training and then you have
features or new input data new inference
data or new features and models and you
get predictions so that's basically what
you need to build to build a system you
shouldn't be building the infrastructure
you shouldn't be building you know a
feature store or a model registry you
should be just using them so if we can
build these three different programs
they're going to be three python
programs in our example a feature
engineering pipeline a model training
program an inference program you're not
going to learn state-of-the-art model
training in this talk so if you're here
for for getting the best model training
probably best to go somewhere else but
what we're going to do is look at how
the data can flow easily and how we can
build this system without too much
effort if you know python if you know
pandas you can get through this very
quickly
rice
any questions at this point just share
with me a few questions or put up your
hand
okay let's keep going
so what we're going to do is write these
three programs the feature pipeline
train pipe and inference pipeline to
build an air quality prediction service
we need some technology to do that we'll
use helps works as the state layer and
we'll use I was going to use my laptop
but now I'm on someone else's laptop and
I was going to run Jupiter notebooks on
my laptop that's how I would normally do
it but unfortunately I couldn't and I
won't be able to run modal because it's
not my laptop here but I'll show you the
code and we'll talk through it and then
you can do a user interface and in this
case I'm using streamlit as the user
interface and python there's two
Frameworks that are very popular radio
and streamlit I did this in in streamlit
and then you can run that on two free
cloud services one is hogging face
spaces and the other one is streamlit
cloud
okay I mentioned this already a machine
Learning System any machine Learning
System you build can be built out of
these three independent machine learning
pipelines the feature pipeline the
training pipeline the inference pipeline
all three of them have different
requirements so maybe the feature
pipeline needs to run once a day
maybe the entrance pipeline needs to run
four times a day it's a batch inference
pipeline maybe the inference pipeline is
online it's an it's an online
interactive application that's using a
model to make Intelligent Decisions so
it's an online feature pipeline maybe
the training pipeline runs once a week
or maybe you only run it when you think
the model has degraded you run it from a
colad notebook that's totally fine but
what this gives you is the ability to
decompose the problem of building a
machine learning system which is a huge
challenge into three independent parts
that you can work at independently you
can even have different teams doing them
but it's all in Python so if you're a
data scientist working python you should
be able to build this
so the I've called this a minimal
minimal viable prediction service and
what I think basically data scientists
should be doing now when they're talking
to their stakeholders and you're
presenting your models is not going and
saying here's my model I evaluated on
this test set I got 95 accuracy it's a
classification problem
um or here's an F1 score that says
nothing to the stakeholders you build a
service which shows the model living in
the ecosystem where it should be built
and you do it iteratively so you want to
get to the your first goal should be get
to a minimal viable prediction Service
as fast as possible do the absolute
minimum when we're training models we
always talk about bass lines the same is
true for feature pipelines and inference
pipelines and you need the minimum
viable prediction service needs to start
with it with a problem that you're
trying to solve so a prediction service
or prediction problem if you're working
in Industry often there's business kpis
associated with it you need to know
where the data is coming from and you
have to start at that point on the left
once you've started on it your goal is
to get this minimum file prediction
Service as fast as possible and then
iteratively improve it and the consumer
could be user interface could be a
dashboard it could be a a system you're
going to integrate with whatever it's
fine
so
we've said there's three different
pipelines ml pipelines feature training
and inference this particular system the
air quality prediction system consists
of a feature pipeline which takes two
different data sources one is weather
data and the other is air quality data
and then we have a training pipeline
I've been running up my notebook
unfortunately I won't be able to run it
now but we'll look through the code
and then we have a batch inference
pipeline so in fact I simplified a
little bit by removing the batch
inference pipeline the batch inference
pipelines generally they often output
for dashboards so maybe they're going to
write to a database then you have a
dashboard consuming it from the database
or maybe you produce images and I've
done that in in other projects where you
have GitHub Pages hosting the dashboard
so that's where we get refreshed once
per day or once per hour
um I did an interesting one on
predicting surf Heights at a beach beach
in Ireland and once a day it predicts
the new surf Heights and that's a GitHub
page but what I'm going to do is just
remove the batch inference pipeline
we'll have an interactive application
and that's the one that we saw earlier
and that one is actually being hosted on
stream list not on hooking face but
they're both effectively equivalent with
some caveats
okay so that's what we're going to do
and a little bit more detail
because it's in the devil's in the
detail obviously so before if you
remember what we said was we're going to
have these um this is our architecture
from before we said hey we've got a
feature engineering step we've got a
model training step and we've got an
inference step and data is being written
out there but like if we see this data
here let's look at that in actual more
detail what are we going to do well
firstly we're going to work in Python
only as we said we're going to work with
pandas so the feature pipeline is a
program which will take the data in
create pandas data frames we can do some
feature Engineering in pandas and then
we write the data frame which contains
our features and in this case also our
labels
to a table in the feature store it's
called a feature group so the API is
create Panda's data frame right to the
feature group and
if you're if you have large volumes of
data you can do this with spark as well
our platform also supports beam and
Flink so there's many different ways you
can create features depending on your
requirements but that's the basic of the
feature pipeline the training pipeline
will read our features and labels
and it'll train a model and we'll write
the model back to the platform and then
our inference pipeline it's going to be
a a small Python program with the UI
it'll download the model it'll download
the data that's going to make
predictions with and then you select
your cities and it makes a prediction
for you and what we can see here is that
it's reading the data the training
pipeline the inference pipeline are
reading data from something called a
feature View
now the feature view is is it's it's
metadata there's no State there it's a
selection of features from different
feature groups when you want to create a
model you'll say I want this feature
this feature this feature this feature
and that is your feature View and one of
the problems or challenges of making
systems and machine learning is this
unified access to data from training and
from inference and this is what the
feature view solves that problem for you
it gives you a single API where you can
get training data you can get batch
inference data you can get individual
records that you use or feature vectors
as we call them if you have an online
inference model
okay the data that we're using in the
course I actually had them subscribing
to these services and getting API keys
but we discovered a really cool site
openmatio and that actually gives you
some air quality data air quality
there's like 20 different measures of
air quality uh the most common one is
called pm25 but openmatio actually gives
you pm25 observations not it doesn't
give you forecasts and what's
interesting as well is that um you would
think that air quality prediction
service that there's one everywhere
right you would think like oh you know
there must be an air quality prediction
service for Seattle I don't think so I
had a quick Google I couldn't find one
and you know some cities like Beijing
and Delhi will have them but
um very many cities don't and in
particular what they don't have is it
localized to your area you probably know
that if you live in the sand there's
more wind and uh you know the air
quality is better but it'll be nice to
have data on that
so this is what the data looks like this
is just a kind of a a very very high
level view of it and you can see we have
the top we have a city name and then we
have a date so data is the observation
of the weather data
and then we have a bunch of features and
the features here are wind speed Max the
direction of the wind the gust Speed Max
temperature max and these all have
feature types so some of them are
numerical features some of them are
categorical and then we have this row of
features here is what we call a feature
vector and the individual feature values
so we call this here this is our primary
key the city name but we call it the
entity ID because each row is uniquely
identified by the combination of entity
ID and event time so that's our that's
in fact our unique identifier for each
row
so that's our weather data and we get it
from uh like I said open messio
and then we've got the air quality and
the air quality has the same two CD name
and date and then we have this pm25
which is our measure measure of air
quality there are many more air
qualities measures out there but the
prediction problem that I have here is I
want to predict air quality so in fact
what I want to do is predict this pm5
value so this is a regression problem
because it's a it's a number
but from a feature store perspective
feature groups contain columns and this
column could be a feature in one model
but it could be a label or a Target in
another model so in this case I'm going
to create a feature view that uses that
as a as a label or Target
okay I mentioned already get started on
on creating account in hopsworks we saw
that already
unfortunately I can't run this code on
my laptop but but it's not super complex
I'll open the GitHub repo and we'll have
a look at it in a second and what you do
basically is you need to and this is
true for modal if you're going to try
model you'll need to do this as well
um I use conda you may have another
virtual environment you prefer
um but basically
um 3.9 is what this is tested on and I
create an environment and then I pip
installed the requirements in this
particular repo
let's open it
and we'll have a quick look so this is
the repo here I did add a bunch of
requirements just for the UI but in
general like for the feature pipeline
you only need hopsworks and if you're
going to use
um modal you need modal client as well
the other one's geopaya for the UI
mostly job lab is for the inference
Pipeline and for the training pipeline
okay
yeah if this is the URL up here it's
it's um github.com Jim dailing it's my
name and then air underscore quality
okay so you can open up that repo there
okay let's dive in and assume you can
you can do that
so um what you'll need to do in
hopsticks if you create an account you
can use Gmail it'll take you 10 seconds
just sign up click with your Gmail
when it creates you have to enter a
project name when you've entered a
project name you can click on this user
settings up here you'll need to create
an API key so you need to enter a name
in here for the API key I typically
click select all create the API key and
then save it right so we'll need to save
that and the same is true for modal
and use mode out you create an account
you'll need to pip install the modal
client so it's modal Dash client and
then when we use hopstrix we'll need to
add an API key as an environment
variable in modal
um I'll open that later we'll have a
look at it
and then hooking face the same so
hooking face again it's free all of
these you can register with with Gmail
and you need to create what's called a
space so these spaces are user
interfaces you get two CPUs and 16
gigabytes of memory which is really
generous and you're going to create a
streamlit app in this case
so they're the basic Preparatory steps
that we need to take
and we also need to add the hopstrix API
key because our inference pipeline is
going to connect to hopsworks to to
download the model and the the features
that we're going to use to score with
okay
let's get started we're going to do
three it's going to be three parts
and the first part is the feature
pipelines right so we're going to write
a feature pipeline now
um
I don't maybe I do have chat GPT here
um writing feature pipelines for modern
data sources is super easy if you have a
gpt4 account I guess most people have
used gpt4 here right
yes chat GPT
so um I do I have I have an account here
it's cool it's logging me in so what I
no it's not logging me in let's try it
out see if it works but what I do is um
uh I use it for feature pipelines to
create to create
um code in fact
and uh one of the things that okay let's
see blah blah
okay is this gonna work for me all right
let's try it let's see if we've got gpt4
it's a little bit better yeah right so
here's here's an example of feature
pipeline that I wrote last year took a
bit it took me a bit of time took me
maybe you know I'm not I'm not the
world's best python programmer I'm
afraid to admit I'm a systems guy but um
took me a few hours to write this and I
did it in chat gbt in like five minutes
so um what I wanted to do was I'll just
pull up the code here this is a I
mentioned this already it's it predicts
web the wave heights at a beach in
Ireland
so this is the beach here and
um
it was based on icml paper that I wrote
many years ago
and let's connect this so so this is the
that's not it here actually it's the web
page let's go to the hinge
so this is what it does here is this web
page once a day they they write out the
height of the wave you can see here it
says the wave height is flat okay so
that's going to be a problem actually
because I had and that's what I had to
code into my other one but basically
what I can do is I can say to chat gbt
um please write it write some python
code
um so we can say here okay
write some python code to extract
the web wave height
uh
from this URL
and I'll paste in my URL and it didn't
kind of work straight off I'm you know
I'm a bit of a hacker so I kind of knew
that okay can I
uh I can inspect right so let's do
inspect here
so I can look at the this and I can say
okay where is this this is inside this
particular
tag so it's inside this particular class
so it's inside this class here so if we
copy this it's it's inside the the class
Carousel weather so I can give it that
hint
it is inside
the div class and we paste it in okay so
oh great regenerate response come on
come on this works I promise you and
it's really good and in fact it gave me
an API that I hadn't used before and I
said please rewrite this with the
requests API and it did so
that's basically how you should be
writing your feature pipelines is my
take if you're if you're doing the kind
of thing I'm talking about here right
um so what I'm talking about here
building prediction services for the
open internet for people to use for free
if you're working in an Enterprise
you'll say well hang on I'm not going to
do this my Enterprise right this is this
is really hard but there are tons of GPT
tools out there if you're going to do
your feature Engineering in SQL you can
say you know select the oldest user in
this table where the user is from
Seattle you know and then it'll like say
select max age from users where uh
location equals Seattle
if you're not greater writing SQL that
will speed you up quite a lot so I think
this is really useful tools for us to
kind of accelerate our development
skills and it means it's going to be
easier to build these type of prediction
Services than it was for me a year ago
which is great means we're going to have
more of them
right so in this case I said that um you
know we have different ways of building
these feature pipelines we can work on
static data or we can have incremental
or what we call batch data now in the
database world or the data world we call
them data pipelines normally and then we
have streaming pipelines which are the
ones that work 24 7 on live data with
very low latency
in this case I'm going to do just static
data so I have actually downloaded a lot
of air quality it's in the repo in the
in a folder called Data and then we're
going to have a batch data pipeline
which is going to read uh it's going to
go and scrape this feature data and it's
going to put it into a panda's data
frame and write it to the feature store
okay
um
so
I could probably run it in a jupyter
notebook actually but let's um let's try
that for the crack for the laugh collab
I do know that I have a file in there
actually that so there's a URL that
needs to be downloaded sorry it reads a
local file can you can you check out a
repo in in colab
anyone know
collab
collaboratory
okay we can look at the code in GitHub
sorry
okay
right
um let's do the following let's just go
to GitHub and let's look at the code to
begin with
if you've got questions just shout at me
uh Heckle you know whatever whatever
for your
okay error underscore quality there we
go
um right so
um I said I'd do this in in Mobile right
model doesn't run
um notebooks but notebooks are great for
teaching so we'll have a look at it in
the feature pipeline in the notebook but
I also have it written here in Moda so
let's have a quick look through it in
fact before we look at that I said there
was a static data dump and then we have
the the batch feature pipeline so the
static data dump what I did here
is I basically I have this this Json
file with all the cities I want to use
for the air quality
so I read them up
and this is what won't run in my modal
notebook unless I check out the whole
repo so I should download that from the
internet in fact I did that in the modal
job because this is the kind of thing
you get in model if you run modal on
your uh on your laptop it's going to
launch container in the cloud right so
in my laptop I'm running it for my
directory I'm running this python file
but the python file reads a local file
in my that's in my directory and model
doesn't know about that so then Moda
becomes a little bit more complex now
you have to mount a share drive and you
have to do a little bit more but it's
good to know that so I to make it easier
I just downloaded this from a URL
so we've got a bunch of cities
and then I have this backfill data so I
have some some historical measurements
of this pm5 particulate
um
levels at these cities
and hopefully you can see this can we is
that readable
okay great
and um yeah we're doing pandas right so
we're going to just read up this
historical data into a pandas data frame
dfus
and then we're going to we have Seattle
here we Lot locations in Seattle
and this date is pretty much good to go
as it is because there's not much to it
so you know we could you could say well
for the pm25 the spread of values is
quite wide it goes from zero to
um up to you know a thousand potentially
and you might say well I want to encode
that so that's something that comes up
again and again with feature stores
should I encode these values before I
write them to the feature store or
should I do it in the training pipeline
well the answer is you do it in the
training pipeline you don't do it when
you're running to the feature store and
the reason why is because when you
encode a value so if you have a
numerical feature and you're normalizing
it or standardizing it if you've got a
categorical feature and you're one hot
encoding it you have a reference set of
data that you need to use to encode
those values so if I'm encoding a
numerical feature and I've got a batch
of data I've got today's data that I'm
that I want to encode well what am I
encoding it against the existing data in
the feature group in the table I'm going
to take read up all that data calculate
the mean let's calculate standard
deviation now standardize right now
write it to the feature store oh whoops
I have to rewrite all the other values
that are in there already because
hey the mean and standard deviation have
changed right so what that means is that
your feature pipelines will get slower
and slower there's going to be this
right right amplification
that's not good right and however when
you're training a model you take a
snapshot of data so you're taking a
snapshot of data if it's time series
data it's pretty clear it's going to be
this
if it's if it's not time series data
take all the data in the features
Feature Feature tables or feature groups
fine but it's a reference of data so now
when we encode the values with respect
to that reference data set
well that's fine if we have new data
coming in on our online inference
Pipeline and we need to encode those
well we know the statistics for this
training data set it's a reference
snapshot so we can then encode them and
in practice that means scikit-learn
pipelines if you like scikit-learn or
pre-processing pipelines and Keras in
our feature view we also support
Transformations so we store that
metadata and you can just say hey you
know encode encode these feature values
for me so that's done in training and
inference pipelines not in feature
Pipelines
okay so this is not doing too much it's
basically getting our air quality data
getting our weather data we've got a lot
more features we can see here in weather
um I don't know if we need all of those
you know rainfall does affect air
quality so probably there's some some
predictive power in it and basically the
feature store all we do maybe if I can
scroll if I can zoom in a tiny bit
maybe a little bit there yeah did that
work I'm scared to touch it yeah we just
basically log into the platform now
um
you can it'll prompt you for for your
API key and you can paste it in or you
can set environment variables so you
don't have to enter it every time
now what I did as well um and this is
something this is you know it's getting
much easier to do this compared to how
you have done it before but how do I
validate the data before it's written in
garbage in garbage out I don't want I'm
scraping data in the internet if I
scrape pm25 values and they're negative
or maybe they're greater than a thousand
they're obviously you know nonsense so
what we can do is we can define an
expectation and Great Expectations to
say hey check all the pm25 values make
sure they're in this expected range and
if they're not
um you know the the feature pipeline
will fail or we'll let the data go in
and we can then inspect it and say Hey
you know we'll remove that
and um so so so that's what's going to
happen here the feature store will
actually do this for us because we just
basically when we're creating this
feature group we say this is the
expectation Suite so so every time
you're writing apply these expectations
before we write it to the actual feature
store
now this is our feature group
and um the reason why you can think of
it as a table right it's a feature table
the reason why we call it a group rather
than a table is because the data will be
available both for batch API access so
large volumes of it but also for low
latency access and in fact in feature
stores that data is replicated in two
different databases you've got a
columnar one which has you know Low Cost
Storage of uh with batch efficient batch
access and then you've got a low latency
key value or you know row oriented
database where you can retrieve feature
vectors uh very efficiently for your
online applications so the data can be
in these two tables so we don't call it
one table it's a group it could be it
could be one table it could be just
offline in this case it's only offline
but it can also be online depending on
the type of model you're training so all
I have to do when I want to insert my
data frame here I'm inserting the data
frame here is I create the feature group
and I can put some metadata in here the
name description we have versioning it's
very important for ML Ops if you don't
have versions for things like feature
groups and you want to make a schema
breaking change how do you do it how do
you manage the pipelines for the old
version the model that use these
features and the new version that use
the new new features
um so this is really important
and then we have the primary key which
uniquely identifies each row and the
event time which is basically the
observation time for for these features
in this table
and so it basically it uploads it there
and then we do the same for our weather
data we can also add metadata
descriptions of individual features like
I did here and then we insert our
weather data here right so let's let's
have a look at what that looks like once
we've inserted it this is hopsworks here
I'm running a new version like the
version that if you if you've registered
it helps with AI you'll be on three zero
this is three two but it's there's only
minor changes
so these are my two feature groups that
appeared so let's look at the air
quality one first
so you can see here there's four
features we've got city name Dace and
pm25 and then Unix time which I don't
know if I actually need it I'll probably
remove it
and the Unix time is also the event time
and so you can insert pandas date times
that's fine or you can have strings and
we can see how this feature group is
used it's used in these four different
training data sets by this feature View
later on and we had I didn't run the
expectations on this earlier but you
would have your expectation results in
here and then you can have tags and
alerts and so on so what you get out of
the box that's nice for free is you can
kind of preview your data so you can see
what's in there
you know so here we have a quick look at
the data so basically really trivial Eda
right so for example if I want to design
my rule for
um you know what's a valid range of pm5
values well I can go down here and say
what the mean was -3 that's not so good
and the max was 476. so like I don't
know how you have a minus three of pm5
2.5 but some there's some garbage in
there right now
um
okay and then the same is true for our
weather
um feature Group which was here
um that one got written in there any
questions any of this it's all pretty
straightforward right
yeah okay
cool so that's our feature pipeline and
I kind of went through a bunch of it
already we need to schedule it to run so
we'd like to run on a schedule
um it's not enough just to run up once
in your notebook
um what kind of things can you do in the
future pipeline I didn't go through I
won't have time to go through all these
but what is feature engineering right
you can you know compute Aggregates at
binning filtering lag features I mean
there's a ton of different things you
can do
um there's there's new things the whole
time and that really honestly that's the
power of python right there are
libraries for all of this in Python so
you know we I hear at least in the
Enterprise space that SQL is the
language for feature engineering but you
know there's just so many things that
you can't do in SQL yet and even spark
is is it doesn't always have these
capabilities Pi Spark
I mentioned this already generally the
features are not encoded in our feature
pipeline
so I did mention that like you know
there are many ways of writing feature
pipelines so often if you have huge
volumes of data SQL and Snowflake and
your data's in Snowflake that's the best
way to go
um you know it's very good for
aggregations and things like that and
today we're going to just do pandas
pandas 2 is great
um you can handle larger volumes of data
polars even better
um but you get to a certain uh you know
data volume where even folders won't
really work for you I I put this at 100
gigabytes maybe it's a bit more but it's
not a terabyte so when you get to
terabytes you need to go to either a
data warehouse
um or to spark you can also use Flink or
spark streaming which are streaming
pipelines they're a little bit more
challenging but what you get is fresher
features and fresher features may be
important for your particular prediction
problem
or may not be
okay
we looked at this already this is the
code to create our feature group and how
to insert our feature that's pretty
straightforward and we insert our two
feature groups
that's pretty okay and what we didn't
look at where how do I do my feature
functions like sorry how do I do my
feature Engineering in pandas
typically what we would say is it's good
practice to Define individual feed
functions to compute individual features
and now there's a guy called Stefan here
from uh he's a startup based on a
framework called Hamilton and Hamilton
has this encoded in its in its
principles that if you can encapsulate
the computation of a feature into an
individual function then teams can
easily work on the feature computation
in parallel you can individually test in
each feature so you can have a unit
tests in particular so if someone were
to change the implementation of feature
and change how the features computed
that's bad right because that's going to
change the data the feature that's
available so you would like to warn
people with unit tests hang on you can't
change you know there's a contract for
that feature and when you change it then
it's going to break uh the it's going to
be incompatible feature data with the
with the data that's already in our
feature group
so a good way of doing this is to Define
your feature functions in as UDS
user-defined functions in in a module
typically what we would do is we would
say the feature group name air quality
in a package called features put the
features as individual names there and
then we can also use those feature
functions in our online inference
pipelines if we if we need to compute
these features in our online inference
pipeline
we use the same code
all right let's have a look at how we
schedule this feature pipeline then
um this is the code for model this is
basically all you need right and it's
not more complex than this so some of
the things that modal solves which are
really
really great for and very easy are here
we can see that we've got an image right
a container so if you're if you're using
a data science platform like maybe you
use sagemaker or something like that you
know they have these pre-made images
like so you pick that one or I'll have
that one well hang on I want this other
Library how do I how do I add it to my
image well you have to kind of build
your own image you have to write the
docker file you have to compile it you
have to upload it you lose a day of work
right in modal you can just pick your
image Debian slim I can pick different
versions I can pip install libraries I
can you know install dependencies or
packages that I need it's really really
great and in fact modal do the same
sorry hugging face do the same for
hooking face spaces you can have custom
Docker images and then you can pip
install any any libraries that are in
the requirements.txt file hugging face
is going to just install them
so and the other thing that model gives
you which is is really nice is the
ability to schedule these pipelines to
run at a Cadence so in this case we want
to run this pipeline once every day and
all I have to do is annotate the
function that I'm going to recall
um with this stub dot function call and
I say the image this is our our Linux
image with this Library houseworks
installed and it's going to run once a
day
and um I also need an API key so I need
this haptics API key in order to connect
to hopsworks to write my data frames to
the feature store well I can get that
from modal here and from this particular
line of cop of code and then all I have
to do down here in my main I'm saying
deploy this as the air quality daily now
the reason why I've got all this weird
stuff say with stuff that run G and so
on
you basically encapsulate your code into
this function so I put all of all of my
feature engineering code into this
function G
now one thing I noticed straight off
when I was doing this with the students
Eric who developed this gave a talk for
them and they they like it they're kind
of like a little bit it's a little bit
hard but not too bad
um but what they found a little bit more
challenging was that you know you don't
always have internet access modal is
super fast I'd love to show you a demo
where it just runs that python code and
gives you the logs in Python in five
seconds but as it's not my laptop I
can't but let's have a look at the code
and one of the things that it's a
feature request that's always going on
there which is that you'd like to be
able to run the code locally and they
currently don't support it so I hacked
it out for the for the course and I
basically set this environment or this
parameter local faults so if you set
local false that means it's running a
model if you set local true it'll just
run on your laptop so then you have this
little hack which says if local is false
well then we do the the modal stuff and
Moda will just call this function
um G
so G is doing the actual work down here
so this is G here but if I'm in local
mode I just recall G right so it'll run
on my local laptop and I can try it out
and then I can schedule the thing to run
model when I'm happy with it so I find
that really good way of working
um and it's pretty uh it feels like you
know normal python pandas development
and it really shortens your your
iteration cycle for for developing
things and putting them into into in
this case we use a term into production
which is exactly what we're doing right
we shouldn't be shy about it you know if
you're if you're um
if you're building a oh God let me see
if this works
uh that's me that looks like me
oh God here we go phone
every everyone is like oh no maybe I
have a European phone will it allow my
European text message to get through
yes it worked
I you know I like the way that they
actually automatically press the button
but really annoys me is that they don't
auto focus on the window right does
anyone else get really annoyed by that
why don't they auto focus on it you have
to click on it again
all right
pet peeves so this is my uh air quality
app that's what it looks like on on
modal here like you know run it like
next run in 18 hours blah blah blah
um the one I was running in the course
was Iris daily totally modern and it ran
lots of times you can see you get your
lugs it's nice you can just go look at
your lugs for a run and say oh
um no logs that remove them all thank
you okay and but it's it's a pretty it's
it's really nice right so it's really
trivial to get started you can create a
new secret you put your API key in there
it's an environment variable and then
off you go
um
if you're doing data engineering and
you're You Know You're Building kind of
complex uh you're used to building
complex dags and airflow and running
these things and scheduling them often
our feature pipelines are not as complex
as building many different data sets
that are consumed by different bi tools
so I find that modal generally is good
enough for a lot of a lot of these uh
potential use cases
right so that's modal and um you know
that thing can run and and the other one
that I mentioned is GitHub actions you
can also do the same thing in GitHub
actions if you're interested go to the
service ml course that I gave where we
use GitHub actions and it's free that's
the benefit of GitHub as well of course
there's a little bit more work to do
it's not as nice
yeah so in Moda you're basically
defining your dependencies the the image
you want the libraries you want the
environment variables and then you run
the thing
it's pretty straightforward
if you're doing good of actions this is
kind of what it looks like this is my
version because it doesn't give you
stuff for finger of actions so what I do
is I install a python version I install
my pip install my requirements I set an
environment variable which is the object
API key and then when I want to run my
notebook I just run NB convert so I have
to add NB convert to my requirements.txt
and it'll convert my notebook into a
Python program and run it
because my python notebook runs as as 95
of python notebooks do from top to
bottom you just run from top to on so
that's pretty okay
excuse me
honestly
um I think you can do training pipelines
this way so you know a lot of us love to
do training in notebooks because we want
to do analytics of the model with the
notebook when we trained it and um I
don't see the harman running these
things as pipe training pipelines on a
schedule I don't know there are biases
that that you know many Engineers uh
have against notebooks in that case but
I think for training Pipelines
um this is often good enough
um I covered this already so I won't go
through it anymore Great Expectations
and what it looks like is you get in in
your feature group you'll see all these
different runs just we saw the runs in
modal we can see the results of our of
our expectations and you can get an
alert you know send a slack message if
there's a problem or something like that
so
that's number one covered which was
feature pipelines now we're going to do
training pipelines this is the easy part
and training pipelines are pretty
straightforward the thing that you want
to do when you know when you've got a
feature store and it's got tons of
features like uber say they have 50 000
features in their feature store which is
quite a lot and what you need to do at
that point is you're not always going to
create novel features for your for your
prediction problem there may be existing
features there for you I think within
near in the near future there's going to
be feature marks it's a term we're using
internally where you can get many of
these existing features and it won't
always be that you have to create new
feature pipelines from scratch but when
you're selecting features if you have
some available some of the things you
should consider is okay is this a useful
feature for my prediction problem does
it have predicted power is it redundant
is there one like that there already I
don't need it is it irrelevant
um if I'm working in Industry of course
I care about and just in the industry if
you've ethically challenged you should
care anyway
um is this okay to use this feature
and then the other one that that I think
stumps a lot of people
um who don't have a systems background
is is this feasible to use this feature
can I compute it in my online
application because that's often a
source of tension in many organizations
you know you'll have a feature that
you'll say okay uh I know this require
it's going to be user input
um I want to it's going to be a string
and I want to encode it um with this one
hot encoding pipeline that scikit-learn
is using will that be okay and the
answer is yes of course but you if you
want to use that feature using a feature
store like hopsworks you would look at
the feature group and say is that
feature available online
you know if it's available online then
yeah sure it'll go straight off if not
well then depends on the model we'll see
how it goes
so the process of selecting features or
feature selection is really just going
to these different tables saying I would
like this this feature join them
together and boom I've got this feature
View
um if you're a data warehousing person
and is there any data where has some
people here dimensional modeling no do
you know what in the course in the
serverless ml course I gave um part of
the course was on uh data modeling
because we don't do enough data modeling
I did work with my SQL before but data
modeling is very inherent because most
data scientists at Enterprises work with
data from data warehouses it's being
modeled into you know either Kimball or
inman's model it's got It's got fact
tables it's got Dimension tables and you
probably have heard those words I have
no idea what they are but they're
basically what what is a fact is for us
a label so a label is the the target the
outcome in this case the the air quality
it has a time stamp so TS is timestamp
and what I want are features at the same
timestamp so what was the air quality
sorry what was the wind speed what was
the wind direction what was the
temperature
um you know what was there precipitation
at the time
I'm joining those those together because
they're the features I'm going to use as
input to this model where I'm predicting
the label or Target in this case which
is the pm5 value
so this is a fact Dimension model and
this and it's not not super hard right
this is actually really easy stuff
um
Okay so
in this case my target is in the air
quality feature group is the pm5 column
um I need to join that with the other
weather column luckily enough I had the
city name is the same and I need the
same date and that's going to give me
the feature view right but there's a
little bit more to creating a feature
view than just selecting the features uh
selecting is obviously the most
important one and you might want to say
what's the target column we use the term
label I prefer Target but whatever I
didn't win that debate and you can
filter out data you can say well I'm
only going to you know work with with
data in Seattle so we'll we'll only only
have data in the this particular feature
view for for Seattle and then you can
also add model specific encoding so
encodings and for for models that use
this particular
um feature view so you might say well
encode the you know the wind speed Max
with a min max scalar
um I'm going to use scikit-learn
pipelines instead of using the
Transformations and feature views but
both of them are valid ways of doing it
now the value of a feature view is that
it's a unified API for training and
inference that's the value that's the
hard thing that's really hard how do we
you know make sure this feature is
usable how to create batch inference
data how to create online inference data
and training data from the same set of
features same selection of features that
I want to use so the feature view is
really a model view if you will it's the
input to the model it's a set of
features that will be in for the model
for training but also for inference and
I had and you may have heard terms like
training serving SKU or
um you know online offline SKU and I had
a little debate with someone on Twitter
recently and he was like um yeah you get
this type of skew you forgot the type of
SKU where uh you know you're using a
feature when you're training but then
you didn't use it in the in the
inference and I said what are you
talking about like because I've been
working with feature stores for quite a
while I'm like you have the feature view
that has a set of features if I'm in
inference and I and I don't have that
feature available I'll see it because it
won't be available in my feature View
and because that's what's available
online it tells me in advance it's the
contract
okay
so how do I create the feature view well
I basically get references to my two
feature groups in this case and then I
select features from them so I'm
selecting only the pm25 from my air
quality but I'm joining it with the uh
all the features in the Weather Group
now um there is a you know internally
there's a a an Optimizer query Optimizer
which knows that the primary keys are
common that we have the city name in
both of the feature groups so it will
join on those
um and also the date and this does
something more complex called the point
in time correct join which I won't get
into too much details but it basically
means that we don't want to have any
future data leakage we don't want to
have for example the two the pm25 label
having weather values in the future
so we want to have them as the weather
values or whether future values being at
the same time as the the pm25 value was
observed
so the feature view is basically this
selection of features here and we we
decide what the label is and give a
description and the name and a version
so it looks like a table right it's just
a table but remember the data is not
being stored it's just metadata and we
don't actually make a copy of any of the
data so what you can do with the feature
view is you can say hey I want to create
some training data and here's a start
time and an end time and we got train
data set version one
a week later there's more data has
arrived you know because the feature
pipeline keeps running every day so I
said give me more training data train
data V2 and I train model V2 and then I
say okay I've got model V2 I'm going to
get some data to make predictions with
to predict what the air quality will be
and so I get batch inference data say
you know featureview.getbatch data
and maybe then I have an online model
which says I only want the row for
Portland you know give me the the
current uh features for for Portland's
weather and I'll make a prediction of
the air quality with that that would be
an online model
so the feature view allows you to create
these
snapshots of data training data or
inference data whether it's batch
inference or online inference and you
can think of it looking like this kind
of from a conceptual perspective that
the data is coming in from the left and
it's it's filling up over time and when
you've trained models you have a like a
snapshot of data over a Time window and
then this doesn't imply all these
problems are time series problems but
you you basically collect data up to a
certain point in time you train a model
and then the model makes predictions on
data that arrives after that point in
time
now
um one thing that feature views they can
have the in at least in in the hubspoix
platform you can have
uh Transformations associated with so if
you know the the feature type if you
know that this is a a numerical feature
well then I can I can use min max scalar
I can use a standardizer so this is
normalizing the feature value this one
is using the ordinal encoder so there's
the the this is the categorical feature
with unordered values if I have ordered
values I might use the label encoder or
I might use the one hot encoder if I if
I care about you know data size data
volume
um and maybe you know in a feed forward
Network I'd I'd need to uh you know have
numerical features for everything so I
need to obviously encode my categorical
feature and I'd like to have gaussian
distributed features for the rest so
that the feed forward network works well
XG boost won't care about that so all I
need to do is encode the categorical
feature and maybe a logistic regression
will want them back in so depending on
your model you know you if you're to do
the transformations in in the feature
view then you would have to have
different feature views for all of these
the other alternative is just use
sklearn pipelines and then have
different training pipelines one for
these three different models feed
forward actually persons disaggregation
and then we're going to save the um the
pipeline object with our model and
that's what I'm going to do in this
example here
so this is our training pipeline I'll
just show you the code because the
notebook's a little bit longer it's not
too long
so here's what's cool about the the the
feature view it's it's like it learn
right I just called train test split and
I give it a test side and I get back my
train set of features my test set of
features my train set of labels in my
test set of labels and now I can go
ahead and say okay I'm going to encode
the um in this case
and the all right it's missing the for
Loop here but it's basically going to
encode any categorical features in there
and this so this is our preprocessor
it's going to apply the categorical
Transformer to any columns that are
categorical variables it's going to do
inside the one hot encoder as the
Transformer
and then it's going to train the model
with XG boost regressor so what we call
C clf which is our pipeline object we
call train uh we we call it we fit it to
the the training set of features and we
pass it then the the training set of
labels
and we now have a trained model
so um you know this is this this is
basically an entire training pipeline
there's not too much to it once you have
the the features in your feature store
and you've created feature view it's
pretty straightforward so once you've
trained your model we need to save it
because we want to have an inference
pipelines coming after it so in this
case we're using hofstrax feature view
because it's our feature model registry
sorry because it's it's it's easy to use
you can use it other platforms out there
like ml flow which is pretty good but
it's not serverless if you want to use a
serverless model registry other ones
weights and biases have one we have a we
have a there's some notebooks showing
you how to use advices moderator I think
it's a little bit more complex
in this case what we do is we we
basically serialize the the pipeline
object
using job lab we then get the schema for
our model using the uh in this case the
features and the labels it doesn't
matter if you pass in the training or
test sets here and because they're both
the same set of features
and then we can even store um you know
if I if I evaluate the model on the test
set and I get an accuracy or you know in
this case it's a regression problem so
it shouldn't be accuracy
um but um you know if we get some loss
uh you know sometimes last metric in
here we can store it we can also store
an input example so if we deploy the
model get an immediate example of uh
features that you just press test the
model if you're even deploying it as a
service as a model deployment an
inference on model serving info
and then you say the scheme of the model
and then you basically save this
directory so when you save the model um
you can also stick in you know images in
there so they'll all appear in the model
registry so you can see the you know the
the performance of the model and so on
and that's kind of a nice way of doing
it so let's have a look at that in code
and we'll look at it in the platform
first actually
um
I need to go to change it to data
science profile here
okay so this is the model I trained
earlier air quality XG boost
you can see there's some so the metrics
here where the root mean squared error
and the mean squared error and we had r
squared and also we can see then the
scheme and so on so you can also have a
look at the model files I think I saved
an image with this yes the residual
errors so the notebook computed these
not great
there's another version of this tutorial
in our uh in hopster's tutorials which
gives you better performance and this
was me hacking it out I want to make a
little bit easier to read
but let's look at that actual notebook
then
you've got questions just shared at me
I'm I'm going 100 miles an hour here
okay
so this is it here it's the training um
and data set modeling so
this notebook is going to
um we can see here we installed a bunch
of visualization libraries as well
because we're going to do valuation in
here as well but we connect to the
feature store we get reference to our
feature groups we create uh we select
the features from those feature groups
into this object called the query object
you can read data and sort of have a
look at it to see you know what the data
will look like um from that feature View
and inspect it before you actually go
ahead and create the feature View
um if you're using the the managed
version that I mentioned at the
beginning after hubstep yeah it's on
hubster three zeros you'll have to
uncomment this line and commentate this
line because this gettercreate is only
from three 3.1 and but I ran it here so
it'll either get or create the feature
View
and then we can
um go ahead and get some training data
so here we're getting our training data
uh back as pandas data frames so we've
got these four Panda data frames for the
training and test set the features and
labels you can also create if you've got
a large volume of data from pandas you
can also say create training uh data as
files so it can be CSV or parquet or TF
Rec or and even if it's pet or like
terabytes of data you can still do it
from your python notebook because what
will happen is it'll kick off a spark
gel in the back end that will do this
point in time correct join and write the
data out to wherever you want to write
it to so it could be to an S3 bucket or
to the file system in our platform
okay so
um so just have a quick look at what
came out there
oh
Mac is hitting me here
I don't like Max never liked them no
offense
you're okay you're in Washington you're
not I'm not in California now right
and it's where it's safe space is it
I hope okay
um God see it did me again
all right I actually have this problem a
lot with my students I'm going like oh
geez Mac I get like some sort of
post-traumatic
uh trauma that I have to use them like
so yeah this is the code we looked
earlier it's training the model we're
doing Computing our metrics
uh just doing some uh plotting of the
feature importance and things like that
and then we save our model
um so we get a reference to the model
registry and then save it there so
that's basically our training pipeline
not too much else you can do I wouldn't
normally do this in the same notebook
but you can try it out then I test it at
the end just to see you know how things
were working make some predictions on on
a batch of data but you don't need
necessarily to do that so that's the
training pipeline
so it's got an inference left any
questions on that no
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna get this
one done and then we'll come a little
bit on the principles of mlops and then
we're done
and then you can go ahead and go build
one of these things
so there are different types of
inference pipelines there's basically
three different types you'll see out
there the batch inference pipeline is
one that runs on a schedule maybe once
in this case we're running it once per
day what we do is we get a reference to
our feature view we get a batch of data
in this case I say hey give me all of
the data starting from today so what
it's actually going to do is it's going
to pull the weather features out
that are starting from today but when we
our future pipeline is riding the
weather forecast for the next seven or
ten days
so when I say getting from today it gets
all the data from today so we get all
the weather features going forwards
seven to 12 days I can't remember how
many days it is
so this is our data frame that we're
gonna we're gonna score we get a
reference to our model by basically
downloading it and then deserializing it
and typically you know if we're using
streamlit earlier on it'll cache this
um and then we just basically call
predict on our data frame in this case
because I trained on a data frame so I
can predict on the data frame and then
these predictions
um you know depending on how you want to
to consume them or or if you want to
send them to some sync
you know you can write them to a
database if they're going to be consumed
by a dashboard you can create a an image
in in GitHub what I did was I created
images you know like uh with matplotlib
or whatever Seaborn and saved it as a
local file and then in GitHub actions I
committed that local file and that ended
up being the the image that you would
see on the GitHub Pages account
now the online inference uh model is is
it's an online model and that means that
we've got an interact application the
user is potentially entering some data
and we need to featurize that data and
we need to read a pre-computed features
in the future store join them together
and then we make the prediction
so in this case imagine
um I have the city name coming in from
the user interface where we go back here
and I'm using that city name to retrieve
the feature values the weather for that
feature for the next week and I get it
back as a python array if I had other
features which needed to be computed
from DUI I would pass them in here as as
other features they won't be re-read
pre-computed from the feature store
so that I'm calling predict on and
getting my predictions back there and
I'd pass them back to the user interface
so in this case it will be the pm5 2.5
values
now the other one I'm going to skip over
is a streaming kind of models in
streaming applications they like if it's
not human facing but if it's a machine
to machine Pipeline and that's taking in
events coming into Kafka for example and
you're making predictions on them and
writing them at somewhere else maybe to
another Kafka topic and that's the other
one I'll skip over that right so let's
have a quick look at the code for that
now um do I have hooking faces open
hooking face open here I don't let's
have a quick look
so um hooking face faces no I'm not
logged in of course I'm not
oh we remembered something
this is a miracle okay here we go air
quality so I got a bunch of them here so
I actually did this earlier I was just
messing around
um so what it's doing here is you can
see it's connecting blah blah blah this
is running the the program so the
program is actually in here this is hug
and face spaces if you don't know like I
said it's free you get 16 gigabytes and
two CPUs for free which is
brought their 150 million and VC money
is being spent on thank you very much
and but basically what I did was I was
very lazy you normally you would clone
this repo and then you know update the
data and push it but I hadn't
registered my SSH key so I was just like
I just uploaded the files you can do it
in the UI you can just like click add
file and uploaded them so um this is my
inference pipeline or program here it
it's basically
it's an online inference program but
it's not using the online feature store
it's actually just going to download the
um
it's going to download the model so this
is it here
so what it does is it's using streamlit
to print out this stuff that we saw
there you know it's going to print out
getting the feature View getting a batch
of data downloading the model
um and then this is plotting the model
and making it look nice
um downloading the set of cities to open
that we're going to make predictions
with and connect through the feature
store so it's basically kind of stuff
we've looked at already
um
and then there's also some support here
because you can click on the map to
select the cities you want to predict
for so that's in there here but it's
it's all just pure python codes you can
do these uis in Python and it's not
particularly intimidating if I'm to be
honest and um
then you press this button to that we
saw earlier and this is it here where I
can make my predictions right this is
where we select our cities and
um this is where it's like you know
connecting and showing some of the data
um this is not the world's best UI but
there are loads of better ones out there
that you can check out
so it's pretty straightforward to do UI
and python like if you're a data
scientist and when you show off and you
know your model to your boss
the the value that this gives to
stakeholders compared to just showing
the F1 score is enormous you know if
you're going to do recommendation system
or if you can do churn if you're going
to do whatever type of prediction
problem you're dealing with
allowing them to play with it and to you
know to maybe you know try different
values and see how things work uh it
gives them a much better insight into
you know the value that you're adding
with your machine learning
that's it right that was our three so an
ml system is three parts it's the
feature pipeline training pipeline the
inference pipeline you put them together
you don't build the end for just use
these existing serverless services that
are out there and you can build
um full machine learning systems
so if you've built your system and
you're happy with it then you've got
into the boring part of what we call
mlops which is how do I operate this
thing and make sure it keeps running
because you want to make it better you
know you've written a program you're
happy with it you say look it's nice but
then you got an idea jeez you know I can
yeah that other feature if I can add
that one it would be great
so all ml enable products will evolve
over time
and the available input data that's
there will change you know the target
trying to predict will change
ml Ops is not not about kubernetes or
Docker or uh you know Jenkins right now
it is about it is about however
um being able to move faster while not
breaking things so not doing the
Facebook way so basically saying we want
to iterate as quickly as possible but I
want to be confident that the changes I
make will not break stuff
so you do have to care about testing you
have to care about testing and if we
think about testing it's it's really a
pyramid so testing is very much a
pyramid and we'll look at in a second
the other thing that you need to carry
about is versioning they're the two
building blocks of ml Ops are versioning
and testing so we need to test features
we need to test models because our
models are being built on features and
if the features aren't being tested and
the features are broken well then we're
not going to have good models and if
we're building AI enabled applications
on models the models need to be tested
otherwise the ml applications might be
broken so it's really a pyramid and
these tasks should be run as part of
cacd workflow but you don't necessarily
need to learn Jenkins to do it you can
use there's plenty of other tooling out
there that's easier to get started with
so
ml systems are ultimately built from raw
data that we necessarily is not trusted
we may have logic for our features we
can use Pi test to compute unit tests
for our features we can use Great
Expectations we saw earlier to validate
the data and once we've tested so once
we've we've tested these features and
we've valid the data we can pass it on
the models can now with confidence
be trained and say okay you know this
model
um appears to to pass all our validation
tests it's good enough we can pass it on
then to the app and the app can test
that model versus the previous version
of the model with an A B test or a blue
green test
and this is basically how we we build
these systems now the other building
block of
um ml Ops is versioning
and versioning is not as obvious a part
right but it's not something that people
talk about too much
so in machine learning we don't talk
about data in general right we have ml
artifacts right so the ml artifacts that
we care the most about are the features
and the models now there are some
intermediate ml artifacts like you have
a training data set which is a snapshot
of feature data and you know
the models that are are obviously going
to be immutable about the features
coming from the feature groups that's
not immutable they they change over time
there's new features added
and in ml apps we say that hey I want
you know I have a new version of my air
quality model and it's going to be much
better it's going to be air quality
version two right it's like you know
um what did I do well I found some new
air quality data and it's better quality
than the previous one and I can't mix
the old feature data with the new
feature data because then my models
would be terrible so I'm going to create
a new version of this feature group air
quality V2 and the old one will stay
there I'm not going to throw it away
um but I'm going to train my model with
this new new V2 and use the the weather
features in V1 that was fine so I get
model V2 I press upgrade and and now
model V2 is going into production so the
kind of problem you can have of course
is that that you know there's a problem
right so you want to roll back so how do
we do it first we upgrade everything's
good so if you want to Define ml apps uh
in one word I would say it's the big red
button that's not one word is it sorry
it's three words
um so ml if you have a big red button
where you can roll back any changes you
make that's that is that is nirvana
right then you can basically you can say
hey I'm confident to deploy new models
because I know that if I deploy it I can
always roll back to the previous version
but we saw that models are connected to
Features so models need the features
from the feature store and they need
version one they don't need version two
version one of the air quality model
only uses version one of the air quality
feature group
so we need to keep them around the
features and the models until eventually
we say okay I don't care about air
quality V1 but now we need to get rid of
both the feature group and the models
you know and then you can't roll back
now I did mention that um you know mlops
is not about
Docker or not about
um kubernetes or Cloud infra but it is
about testing and testing you know mlops
does come from devops and and the basic
principles of devops are successful for
building reliable systems and being able
to iterate faster being able to make
small changes and deploy applications
every few hours that's been quite
revolutionary for application developers
and the same should be true for machine
learning you know if you write enough
tests and when you're training your
models sorry not training your models
but when you're also creating your your
features so if we have some unit testing
for our features
and around and I run those before I I
push I create a a PR and git push them
to my staging feature store and then
it'll do a pipeline run and make sure
the pipeline runs are okay have some
sub-sample data make sure the data
validation rules are okay and then
um then I kind of push to production and
I end up with an orchestrator so the
three pipelines that we talked about
feature pipelines inference pipelines
and training pipelines they will need to
be orchestrated so it's not enough just
to orchestrate a feature pipeline you'll
need to orchestrate a batch inference
pipeline probably your training
pipelines will need to be run on a
schedule as well
sometimes you'll need to backfill data
as well you say okay you know I need
historical data let's let's run a
production job to backfill it
um models when you're doing CI CD for
models
um the kind of things that I find is
really useful is to have a sub sample of
data in your GitHub repo and what that
means basically
um is that sorry you don't have to
actually but
it means you can train your models
faster but like one of the things that
that's very useful when you've trained a
model with the feature store is that
it's very easy to what create what I
call an evaluation set so typically we
know that we should evaluate our models
on holdout data sets a test set
but if you evaluate your model and on
just the test set which is
representative of all the data then
maybe your model has good enough
performance so it's accuracy or loss is
is good but maybe there's some subgroups
where the model is biased against all
right and maybe you know in advance what
those subgroups are it's gender it's
ethnicity it's it's whatever it's
geographic location wouldn't it be easy
if you could just create those subsets
from the test set and evaluate your
model and all of those different subsets
or we call evaluation sets and now you
can see if the model is performing
similar on all of them and you can even
automate that by you know checking the
statistical difference between the
models performance for those different
groups and that that's where a feature
view you just basically say hey create
test set and then filter on whatever you
want to filter on whether it's gender or
or ethnicity or whatever you want to
test for bias against
okay
yeah and then finally when you've
deployed a model and there are you know
a lot of people deploy models on uh
containers on python they like Fast API
it's great but there are like model
serving Frameworks like this is K serve
here but there's also you know
databricks have one and there's
sagemaker and they give you nice things
like a b testing so what's called blue
green testing so you can have your model
in deployment and then all the traffic
is going to that but 10 percent of the
traffic is being sent to your new now
the green model when you're testing so
you'll see the performance of it if it's
working well
then you can increase up 10 to 50
percent and then 100 and then switch the
traffic to your new model when you're
confident so it's great to have these
kind of capabilities
and to build really production machine
learning systems
and the other thing that about ml apps
is that
um
when we have versioning and testing we
often have to debug systems so we want
to log
um you know the predictions we want to
log the features and we want to also be
able to to go up and down the stack we
want to know this is the prediction made
on this model deployment
what model did it come from what feature
view our training data set created was
used to train that model and what
features it come from what feature
groups did that come from
so this is very useful in being able to
debug uh problems in your in your
systems another thing just in terms of
logging I mentioned we have encoded
feature data non-encoded you typically
want to log the unencoded
and that's why it's good to do the
encoding in the inference pipeline
because if you're if you're doing your
encoding in the feature Pipeline and
you're logging in the inference pipeline
good luck in in being able to understand
what's happening if you've normalized
your numerical features or one hot
encoded your categorical feature is
going to be hard to debug any problems
and then for versioning the like if we
just take how do you do versioning in a
platform like hops works well you can
basically create a new version of a
feature group and and a new version of
feature group is a schema breaking
change adding new columns is not schema
breaking if they have a default value
that's fine and but if you want to drop
a column or if you want to change how
you've got this embedding and embedding
algorithm sucks I'm going to change to a
new embedding you can't mix the data
from the old embedding the old feature
data with the new one so you need to
create a new version of your feature
group sometimes you have to backfill
them with this existing data but there
are some optimizations you can do you
can create like a new feature group with
just the cut the feature that you want
to you what new feature you want and
then you can create feature views that
join it with the with the older versions
so that's it I you know we've got a
couple of minutes left but that's good I
always like to finish a little bit ahead
of time to get a rest but um what are
your ideas like I haven't gotten ideas
for serverless ML systems like we've
talked about about how to build them
here
um you know how to write our three
different pipelines but uh I found this
I gave I mentioned the course ID 223 kdh
and uh there were 96 students in groups
of
two so there was like 40 I don't know
whatever 48 different groups
and I said look here's the air quality
project you know go ahead and I gave
them some of the code I gave them the
basic code for it so the feature
pipelines I said go off and and build
that but I would prefer if you want to
get an excellent grade you have to come
up with your own prediction problem and
get approved by me first
so um there is a website with tons of
them I'll actually be able to find it
here because this thing is kind of
working
um id223 here we go
and just give you an idea of some of
them
um we have football betting predictions
bitcoin price predictions
I mean they're kind of easy enough ones
removing voice from songs which is
pretty cool
um
house price predictions everyone cares
about ski uh snow depth prediction which
you might think is just totally
correlated with weather but it actually
at the end of the season it's hard to
predict you know when will the snow get
too low so like it depends on sunlight
as well as temperature
um electricity price prediction there's
one electricity price demand in New York
predicting crimeans SF that's not hard
I don't know if you need to do that it's
High
um but yeah so you can see there's a lot
of links in here if you Google this
you'll find it I think it's covering
some place here's another cool project
that we did is the lab actually is
really straightforward um
we use whisper so if you're not familiar
with whisper um
whisper is a pre-trained model by hoging
face that can transcribe text so it
transcribes audio
so there we of course we come from all
over the world so what they were able to
do is fine tune The Whisper model for
their language their their mother tongue
if you weren't Swedish someone did it
for Swedish
and um so then in fact the The Notebook
we used by um hogging face what it does
is it needs a GPU so you run it and
collab the problem is it spends 45
minutes 45 minutes Computing features
and you do not need the GPU for that now
any of you who know colab knows you get
like 90 minutes in collab before you the
gpus like pulled from you so most of the
time or at least half the time or more
is is not using the GPU so what they had
to do was break up this notebook into a
feature Pipeline and a training pipeline
so the feature pipeline ran for 45
minutes it outputted then the uh the
encoded
in this case sound data they're going to
fine tune with and they stored into
Google drive it was about 15 gigs it
just fit in everyone's Google Drive and
then you so you could use something to
use hopsworks but I think Google Drive
is good enough as a feature store in
this case
and then you had a training pipeline so
in in this case if you want to do really
good they'd have to save the weights and
um you know you would say save the
weights because Google would yank the
GPU from you
um and uh then you can restart the
training from from your saved weights
here's the kind of things people are
doing this is back in in November
October
and here's the line you know this is a
cast so you have to say in Swedish the
word cat which funnily enough is cat
and it will tell you if you sell it
correctly or not and it does Banana
which is banon and you have to kind of
guess that so um other you know other
ones we're taking Swedish language and
transcribing it and then chaining it so
you know translating into English others
were doing uh at that time chat GPT to
summarize text so it would take a
podcast and then you would transcribe
the podcast and then you would run it
through chat GPT to summarize the text
so there's a lot of really cool stuff
you can do these days and you know these
are the first uh Galician language
transcribing systems in the world and
even Swedish I think that's pretty cool
and it's not hard right this was like
literally a 10-day lab that they had to
do
so hopefully that'll motivate you a
little bit that that this is not
something that's too hard out there
here's my idea stupid idea personalized
gbt4 chat gbt so the feature store would
give you history and context you can
have a vector database to give you like
handcrafted prompts
you know when if I'm if I'm doing a uh
you know a churn model chat GPT doesn't
help me too much it says a churn is this
you know but what if I had all the data
about your customers I knew about your
customers it's in the feature store I
knew the amount of churn I knew the
amount of products and then and then I
have a vector database with some you
know nice uh handcrafted prompts
um then it would be great then I could
have like a personalized chat gbt
and that's the kind of thing you can do
it's pretty cool uh ideas aren't worth
very much
um but you know they're they're worth
something when you implement them
so if you want to learn more about this
we do have a community it's a very
nascent Community like it's about
thousand people on the Discord
please give us a star on GitHub if
you're if you thought this was
interesting
um the course is out there already I'll
do a new version of the course with
probably with modal and a hooking face
at some point this year if I ever have
time uh which I never have but that's
just the way it goes so um that's it and
uh
any questions
thank you
[Applause]